hi my name is James Cole I'm a medical
laboratory scientists physicists
chemists and molecular biologists have
linked energy-dependent changes in DNA
base pairs from angstroms to ecosystems
and healthy longevity in all living
gennaro energy is information the innate
immune system links the information from
the epigenetic landscape to the de novo
creation of genes and to the physical
landscape of supercoiled DNA
energy-dependent super coiled DNA
protects the organized genomes of all
living genera from virus driven energy
theft energy theft causes the
accumulation of mutations that leads to
all pathology in this presentation I
linked ecological variation to energy
dependent rna-mediated events and
ecological adaptation chemical ecology
links the energy dependent events from
nutrient dependent micro RNA flanking
sequences to bio physically constrained
protein folding chemistry rna-mediated
protein folding chemistry links the
conserved molecular mechanisms of cell
type differentiation to all biodiversity
simply put the sons of biological energy
links what organisms eat to cell type
differentiation via the physiology of
reproduction transgenerational
epigenetic inheritance links single
nucleotide polymorphisms and
rna-mediated amino acid substitutions
such as co mt val 158 net and bdnf val
66 met to differences in phenotypes
fixed amino acid substitutions
exemplified differences in the
morphological and behavioral phenotypes
of all living genera the color-coded
sections of the model include links to
cited works that support the brief
representations in the text the center
section of the poster attests to the
fact that cause and effect is non linear
experience driven changes link energy
from physics and chemistry to molecular
epigenetics via rna-mediated protein
folding that's how experience links
top-down causation from sunlight to
molecular epigenetics and the
morphological and behavioral phenotypes
of all living genera across their life
span all life-sustaining interactions
must be integrated during life history
transitions and successful transitions
are manifested has fixed amino acid
substitutions the sections in yellow
green and white link the anti-entropic
quantized energy of the Sun from the
virus idle effects of ultraviolet light
to healthy longevity the citations
attest to facts about energy dependent
hydrogen atom transfer in DNA base pairs
in solution bio physically constrained
protein folding chemistry links hydrogen
atom transfer from angstroms to
ecosystems liya pH in the context of
cell type differentiation facts about
measured analytes in addition to ph lake
rna-mediated amino acid substitutions to
the energy dependent physiology
production all facts about cell type
differentiation link bio physically
constrained at protein folding chemistry
to pH and protection from virus driven
entropy for contrast everything in red
links excessive nutrients dress and/or
social stress from changes in pH and
virus driven energy theft to mutations
and all pathology if everything in
yellow green white and red is not
considered in the context of healthy
longevity compared to virus driven
pathology researchers and clinicians are
left with theories in the context of
genetics and genomics all theories are
equally irrelevant compared to the facts
that link angstroms to ecosystems
virtually all theories ignore
Schrodinger's claims about the
anti-entropic energy of sunlight and
most theories also ignored the San skis
claims about nutrient dependent amino
acid substitutions and biodiversity
facts link chemical ecology from quantum
physics to olfaction and facts link the
immune system and a sense of smell the
sense of smell is linked from symptoms
of neurodegenerative diseases like
Alzheimer's to the hard problem of
consciousness the sense of smell also
links the bull sperm micro RNA ohm to
micro RNAs and human breast milk that
are essential to brain development brain
development occurs in the context of
fixation of rna-mediated amino acid
substitutions that stabilize organized
genomes in the age of precision medicine
and problems with energy theft due to
the Zika virus and other viruses
genomics and genetics must be linked by
facts
about cell type differentiation what is
known about micro biomes metabolism
mitochondria and molecular diagnostics
links this energy dependent systems
approach from the innate immune system
to precision medicine all phenotypic
expression starts with the energy
dependent creation of nucleic acids and
the creation of g-protein coupled
receptors the receptors allow nutrients
to enter cells receptor mediated gene
expression links cephas in the ganado
trope and releasing hormone
neurosecretory neurons of all mammals
from the first step to the final step of
cell type differentiation in all
vertebrates that fact has been known for
more than two decades micro RNA flanking
sequences link nutrient energy dependent
RNA directed DNA methylation and histone
acetylation to the stability of
organized genomes via rna-mediated amino
acid substitutions in all genera that
fact has been known for more than a year
conclusion nutrient energy-dependent
changes link olfaction and c faust
expression from micro RNAs to changes in
the innate immune system via micro RNA
flanking sequences and energy dependent
DNA methylation that varies with stress
in mammals DNA methylation and micro RNA
activity linked gene activation from
olfaction to hormone organized and
hormone activated behaviors by the
secretion of hypothalamic gnrh and
downstream effects on the hypothalamic
pituitary gonadal and the
hypothalamic-pituitary-adrenal axis one
base pair change and a single RNA
amino acid substitution link the
stability of viruses to the stability of
metabolic networks and genetic networks
in the organized genomes of all and in
generic unfortunately energy-dependent
rna-mediated amino acid substitutions
are frequently called beneficial
mutations by theorists definitions of
mutations and assumptions about what
mutations do has biased biodiversity
research and patient outcomes since
d'bries defined mutation in 1904 thank
you